Jake really awesome to have you here
thanks thanks for coming back to YC and
spending some time with us and spend
some time on the mic absolutely cool so
um I wanted to ask you a few questions
about yourself first of all like you've
got a really cool background you got
started in this industry a long time ago
as a youngster and have been at some
interesting company so tell us how you
kind of got involved in tech and where
you've been and and how you're today at
lend up yeah absolutely so I grew up in
the Bay Area
so I was here during the first comm boom
and when I was a teenager I was really
interested in in tech in to two main
areas actually were messing around with
computers and video production and so
the two companies that I really wanted
to work for when I was a teenager and
that I applied to summer internships for
that I really was excited about where
Yahoo and Pixar which you know obviously
your your background in pixel yeah the
place isn't bad it's yeah it's pretty
awesome place and Yahoo Yahoo ended up
contacting me about a summer internship
who's not I'm still waiting to hear back
so I'm hoping you can help me there
you're in yeah okay
and so I was in high school I was 16 and
I was looking for a summer internship
and so Yahoo ended up contacting me
about being a production intern so just
coming in and doing anything they need
it so I went in and interviewed my mom
actually drove me to the interview cuz I
was 15 and a half and I had my learner's
permit but I didn't have my license yet
by the time I would get the job I would
have my license so my mom drove me and
then waited outside while I interviewed
with some of the early people at Yahoo
they were about at the time they were 65
ish people and so go private they were
when I interviewed they were still
private by the time I joined that summer
which was the summer of 96 they had gone
public with like 80 people and one point
six million in revenue or something like
that so it was a different every time a
different time so I ended up being a
production intern that summer and worked
on cold calling to try to get listings
for Yahoo classifieds cold calling car
dealerships and getting them to
export their cars and Excel and stuff
like that and then writing Perl scripts
to like munge the data and load it into
our database so immediately got just
thrilled and excited about what was
going on with with tech and with the web
and wanted to be a part of it and sort
of took off from there and never looked
back so went back to Yahoo the next few
summers as I graduated from from college
and with a degree in CS and then went
and joined full time and was there for
about 8 years building a bunch of
different products eventually working my
way up to a more senior sort of
architectural position there and then
after that I moved on to Zynga where a
friend of mine who was a product manager
was building out a team that was
building infrastructure for all the
games so I was building out shared
messaging and communications
infrastructure for the scale of
farmville plus CityVille plus mafia wars
and less words with friends so doing a
lot of user to user messaging and the
gifting system and email system and
things like that so really fun as an
engineer to work on very very high
throughput high volume applications and
really enjoyed that was there for a
couple years through the IPO and then
started on Linda so my brother and Sasha
and I embarked on on that journey great
so tell me so you'd been an engineer at
startups and seen two amazing companies
scale you saw one IPO inside the company
and obviously Yahoo was kind of a legend
to a company for a long time and still a
big company today what what sort of told
you hey it's time to start a company was
that something you always wanted to do
or did Sasha convince you to do it yeah
how's that a little both so I always was
interested conceptually in doing it yeah
but I was never actually steeped in
startup culture even growing up here I
was added what became very rapidly a big
company by the time I joined Zynga they
were 300 something people so never
really was you know was a big fan of
Paul Graham and his essays but never
really got into following startup
culture and so it was never sort of
reading blogs about how to be an
entrepreneur or anything like that I was
pretty focused on the technical craft
and improving my technical skills and so
when Sasha sort of came to me with his
ideas around what we could do to to
reinvent financial services with
technology I got pretty excited by it I
got pretty excited by the impact
potential by the technical challenges
involved but it was definitely a little
bit of a leap of faith it was not
something where I was I was a little bit
used to being at companies that had a
little more structure had a little bit
of a safety net yeah and so I knew I it
was something I had always thought about
and wanted to do but I was it was
definitely a little a little
nerve-racking right to make that leap
right so one of the things among many
things that's special about lend up is
the strong mission the sense of purpose
that you guys have can you talk about
that and talk about you know how that
pervades the culture of the company and
the types of people who work there yeah
absolutely and I mean that was the thing
that and eventually did you know
encouraged me to make that leap
[Music]
Financial Services has such an
incredible impact on so many people and
has by making small and even small
improvements to some of these products
you can really impact people's lives in
a very positive way especially in the
parts of the market that are underserved
or poorly served which is huge right
huge describe that done for the audience
is everything for you so for context so
lend up is essentially a company that is
creating socially responsible financial
services products online focused on the
56% of the United States that doesn't
have access to prime banking and credit
services so that means there's
essentially since 2008 there's been a
huge move based on a number of different
factors in the market and regulation
that have created a lot of financial
exclusion that it basically meant that
there are a lot of people who don't have
access to traditional credit products
and lend up is trying to fill that gap
by offering online personal loans and
credit cards and continuing to build
more products as we build out a whole
ecosystem right that group and these are
people who you know have
but you know potentially poor credit
history and don't have access to banks
and credit unions and therefore need
alternative products right so just just
to put a point on that I think what you
just said is 56% of Americans don't have
the ability to get loans that's right at
reasonable interest rates or credit
cards that admit perhaps at all
and that 56% number is the FICO cutoff
of 680 or below which is what banks
would consider subprime mm-hmm right and
so you guys are focused on that
population focused on that population
and giving them safe constructive credit
products and then tying those credit
products together using incentives and
education and gamification to
essentially help them improve their
financial well-being by incentivizing
the right behavior so we win when they
win we set the products up so that when
they succeed you know we do well as well
and that and that's so going back to
your original question about the mission
that was the the big insight that Sasha
had that really set the company up to be
mission oriented which was that we could
create a product where the consumer
succeeds when we concede when we succeed
and we align those incentives together
so that the consumer can go through
multiple different products in the
ecosystem continue to grow we can
educate them bring in financial services
education and incentivize the best
possible behavior is to help improve
their credit score and get them access
to more money at lower interest rates
and basically just help them improve
their financial lives and have a
long-term relationship with that
customer and have a good relationship
with that customer over the long term
and create a profitable business at the
same time and by doing that we could
force a lot of the incumbents also to
change the way they view this market and
the way that they treat the market which
is in many cases not constructive to the
consumers financial health right I've
seen some of the customer testimonials
your customer testimonials yeah can you
just describe the type of person that
you serve the type of problems that you
help them with just in a just so you
know the listening audience just has a
sense of
sense of that yeah there's there's
actually a pretty wide mix right I think
people's natural instinct is assume
you're dealing with you know low-income
consumers and it's actually you know it
affects income volatility is just a
rising problem the nature of our economy
moving towards a service and information
based economy the gig economy coming up
we see a lot of significant income
volatility huge percentage of our
customers have income fluctuations of
over $200 a month yeah and that makes it
really hard to budget really hard to
plan and it actually affects a wide
group of people so it's not you know it
may not be the person that you might
have in mind there's it really affects a
large group so we we refer to it as the
emerging middle class because it really
is a huge percentage as I said 56% of of
the u.s. we spend a lot of time actually
I personally like to spend a lot of time
in our servicing center and listening to
listening to calls yeah because I feel
like for me it's personally just really
inspiring first of all I get energized
every time I go and there that's
exciting to see the way that the
customers love the product and are
excited about the opportunity when you
give somebody a chance that they may not
have had that other companies wouldn't
take a chance on them the the level of
commitment and loyalty that it generates
is just really amazing but in addition
you know I like being in there because I
see how our products are working whether
they're resonating with consumers what
features we need to be building what
servicing tools we need to be building
for our customer service account
managers to see if we can improve their
efficiency and make their job easier and
better as well so it's just a really
great experience to go in there and hear
about hear from the customers and learn
about it but as I said a lot of them are
struggling with income volatility and
they are you know looking for ways to
smooth out sort of their their financial
lives yeah and that is that is the
common thread that we see a lot right
terrific so you mentioned one thing that
motivated was to start a company it was
the incredible social mission of serving
an underserved population and the second
thing was the opportunity to build your
own technology and do this in a
different
away than the traditional financial
services industry did it can you talk
about that what have you guys built and
what's different in terms of the
technology stack yeah so we sort of
approach the problem you know as my
background as I said is you know
distributed system web application
engineer is actually my first foray into
financial services and I've had to learn
a lot as I went but we approach the
problem kind of from first principles
right how would we want the product to
work and how would all the systems that
support a credit product work in real
time and could we build all that
infrastructure on a modern technology
stack right and by doing that we've been
able to have a bunch of firsts in terms
of customer features and enabling them
to use the product so for example we
were the first company that had fully
algorithmic instant decisioning where we
could someone could apply online for one
of our products and instantly know
whether they got approved for the
product or not and we did that fully
across the board we were the first
lender to roll out instant funding so
that we could deploy capital to people's
bank accounts really rapidly when they
needed it which is a big deal for our
customer segment who are trying to deal
with emergencies that may arise or again
trying to smooth out their financial
lives so coming at it from first
principles and building everything
real-time allows us to make sure all of
the systems that we have that support
those products can work in concert and
what we've seen is that competitors you
know oftentimes are there buying vendor
they're buying their technology from
vendors they think of IT as sort of an
outsourced function in the business and
that gives us a huge advantage because
we have the ability to completely
customize our tooling our efficiency as
I mentioned for our account managers is
much higher than our competitors we have
a fully in-house decisioning system we
can tune to take advantage of new data
sources to roll out new machine learning
models as quickly as possible
and in addition the data pipeline is a
huge part of that we can we have a
holistic view of how all those systems
are working in real time and you know
offline for analytics and you know one
of the one of the first times that I
realized that Linda up was going to be
really successful was early on when we
were starting out
had a competitor call us up and want to
talk potentially about an acquisition
potentially about you know a partnership
and they wanted to learn about the risk
management infrastructure we had built
the real-time decisioning system and
this was a pretty big competitor doing
like a billion dollars a year of
originations and I was thinking man what
am I gonna what am I gonna tell these
guys about risk management that they
don't already know and we got on the
phone with their chief chief risk
officer and the first question he asked
me was when you make a loan to someone
how do you know they don't already have
a loan out with you so very great so I
didn't I genuinely did not understand
the question I was like well like what
do you mean but but he meant it because
his customer relationship management
system and his underwriting and decision
management system taught rich they
didn't talk to each other and so that
was a moment where I was like whoa we're
like we're gonna kill these guys like
you know I mean like we have
infrastructure that can communicate can
adapt in real time and can really help
our customers succeed in ways that you
know they're just not able to right and
so that was a moment where I knew that
we could align you know the mission that
you were talking about before in terms
of helping the customers do better with
efficiencies in the business to make
something that was effective and grow
scalable and sustainable as well got it
so you know financial services banking
lending et Cetera's is highly regulated
its regulated at the I think that the
federal and state level and complicated
different ways how much does that hamper
your ability to kind of build what you
want to build on the technology side or
what unique challenges is that create
for you yeah it definitely creates some
unique challenges so you know you have
to start with every product that you
build you know compliance with all those
state and federal regulations is table
stakes and we have a value at lend up
set the new standard where we say we
want to go above and beyond being
compliant which is the base that you
have to do to meet the requirements of
the law and set a new standard for our
customers our partners and our
regulators but it does you know there is
there is a base level of certain
statutes that you must comply with so in
certain areas
and some of those statutes are written
for an era of pen and paper or you know
in brick-and-mortar right right and so
some of them aren't as relevant so what
we've done is tried to establish really
good relationships with all of our
regulators so that we can have real time
conversations and say hey we want to do
this thing we think it's in line with
the statute we think it's better for the
consumers how do you feel about that and
create a good two-way communication so
that we can try to innovate but there's
also plenty of room for innovation
within the bounds of what the statute
provides and there's also an opportunity
I think from a competitive advantage
perspective to do the compliance better
through technology so automating a lot
of the compliance validation and
automating a lot of the infrastructure
that we use for reporting so we've been
able to get some leverages against you
know other because the compliance
affects everybody in the market not just
us and by using technology we can
actually view that as an advantage got
it there's an element there as well so
you're the CTO of lend up today how big
is your engineering team yeah so we are
60 engineers roughly and growing fast so
hiring as fast as we can right yeah and
what are the kind of the most
interesting problems you're working on
today on the engineering side that
you're psyched about yeah
so I think one of the things we're doing
internally is you know for a long time
we were moving really fast building
technology really quickly and we're
trying to just shift the culture just a
little bit towards one of craftsmanship
all right one of the big the two the two
big engineering values I think are
really critical for a strong engineering
culture are pragmatism and craftsmanship
mm-hmm and pragmatism is about thinking
about what you build in the context of
the business and making sure that you
are building things that are relevant to
the business yeah and craftsmanship is
about building things well and building
them right and having pride in what
you're building on a regular basis and
those two things sometimes feel like
they can be at odds but I actually don't
think they are most of the time most of
the time being pragmatic about what you
choose to build and then building it
really well are not in conflict but I
think we needed to lend up really think
about we
a lot of time thinking about how we
could get to market quickly how we could
build the products and test things very
rapidly and we're trying to build more
of a culture of craftsmanship within the
organization and that means shifting -
every time we build something thinking
about how does it work really really
well for our customer and that's a
change that is challenging it happens
you know as your organization scales and
you have more to lose and more to think
about as you scale your company and it's
it's something that is really critical
as we get to the next level because our
products are not they're not something
people use casually they affect their
lives in a very real and genuine way
they have a huge impact on their daily
lives and so if they don't work really
really well it can have a really
deleterious impact on our customers
right and as I said when I'm in the call
center you know talking to customers if
something doesn't work right I see how
it affects them on a daily basis and so
it's become really important that we
improve the the craftsmanship and
quality of what we do every single day
so that's one of the cultural shifts
that we're making in terms of the
technology challenges specifically
you know there's a huge machine learning
pipeline that we've built that has to do
with taking all the data that we collect
on consumers behavioural data credit
Bureau data everything else that we
collect and enabling our data science
team to analyze that experiment and
build really powerful decision models
models around fraud models around risk
management and just really helping
improve our ability to identify
customers the right product for the
right customer at the right time so
that's it that's a huge challenge that
we're always working on and always
improving that real-time machine
learning infrastructure and then I think
one of the other big ones is how do we
build a best-in-class
data warehouse and data infrastructure
the data that we have is so complex it
comes from so many different sources one
of the things I've learned about
financial services is just the amount
and variance of the data is just really
huge and the reporting similar to the
way the product works and when we're
dealing with people's money the
reporting has to be dead-on accurate
right right so when I was at Zynga and I
was looking at cliques or looking
behavior as long as you were in a ruffle
rough ballpark about how people were
using the product you can make decisions
that were accurate about what to build
next when you're dealing with financial
and compliance reporting every penny has
to add up right and so really improving
our data infrastructure data pipeline is
one of the big things that we're working
on as well
got it I mean you mentioned Zynga and
lend up on the one hand they seem so
different yeah but can you talk about
like what you learned at Zynga that you
were able to apply it Linda yeah
absolutely well for the most obvious one
is about the gamification piece right so
we a bunch of the things that I learned
about at Zynga and how you incentivize
behavior in short and medium long-term
incentives and goals we applied to our
financial products to try to help people
use them as responsibly as possible so
for example we have the way we tie our
loans products together is that a
consumer comes in and takes a short term
small dollar loan and then we
immediately once they've been approved
for that loan and we deposit the money
in their bank account we give them the
opportunity to participate in credit
education and by participating in the
credit education and by payment making
their payments on time they earn points
which then allow them to get access to
larger dollar products at lower interest
rates and with longer terms to help
stabilize them so that entire incentive
structure sort of came out of the
gamification stuff that I had learned at
Zynga there you know I think Zynga had
an incredibly data oriented culture all
the decision-making was data oriented
Mark Pincus was very much a data-driven
CEO and he culturally instilled that
across the company so that's something
we've tried to do as well you know in
when you're having a conversation about
what you should do next what you should
prioritize how to think about what to
build usually someone has data and
someone may not and the person with the
data I can tell the story of why
something is important whereas the other
person might just be telling a you know
their their own narrative of where they
think things may go it's it's always
good to follow the data and let the
actual data tell the story and so that's
something culturally we've tried to
definitely instill you guys lend up has
a couple of credit card products in the
market today and they have some really
neat features that maybe haven't gotten
as much attention as
they deserve can you describe like the
lend up credit card product and some of
the features that I think are only
available on your card yeah absolutely
so we're really excited about the card
product it's it's a nice next natural
step in the ecosystem that we're trying
to create and being able to graduate
people from you know personal
installment loans onto credit cards is
revolving credit product products are
ideal for a lot of customers in terms of
managing that that income volatility
that I mentioned before so we're really
excited about that product and we're
really starting to scale it we've done
some pretty cool stuff with it so first
of all we're really thinking about it as
a mobile first product you know with the
loans product you know the amount of
interaction that you do with that
product on a daily basis as a customer
of that product is not that high yeah
because you're coming in to maybe making
an extension make a payment look at your
balance but it's pretty rare whereas a
credit card is a highly transactional
product it's in your wallet you're using
it on a regular basis you need to you
know you need alerts you need it's a
real-time product and so we're thinking
about that as a mobile first product and
built into the mobile app we actually
partnered with our credit card processor
that we use for interacting with the the
networks and we injected ourselves into
the authorization stream that happens
every time somebody makes a swipe with
one of our cards and what's cool about
that is we don't just see the stream so
that we can do things like push
notifications which actually has not
really been offered in credit cards
beyond the vertically-integrated cards
like Amex and discover there are no
MasterCard and Visa cards that actually
do push notifications you can get them
through Apple pay but you cannot
actually get them through the card
issuer because they're not doing they're
not seeing that stream so we we have
push notifications but not only can we
see the authorizations as they happen in
real time and react but we can actually
participate so we can approve or decline
transactions in real time on behalf of
the customer so what that means is we
are experimenting with a bunch of really
interesting features that allow people
to set limits for what they spend in
various categories or to create fraud
prevention in terms of geo geo fencing
or geo locations where the card has to
be within a certain distance of them or
they have to be in a certain area for it
to work their phone has to be here we
have the card to work and it has to be
within the location of the card so
there's some really interesting stuff we
can do there
and we're experimenting with those
features right now we're rolling out
that app as a beta to our card customers
as we sort of learn more about what's
working there got it cool so can someone
listening to this podcast yet I'll end
up card not yet not yet so where we are
this year we're planning we're hoping to
open it up to open applications right
now it's still a beta program got it
start targeted yeah got it we're scaling
it pretty significantly but it is still
a closed / closed beta got it great so
to be invited yep okay cool okay okay
yeah I want so let me ask you so what
you described at the beginning of the
podcasts you've been in this industry a
long time you got involved in I think
you said you were 15 and a half my mom
drove you to Yahoo for for an interview
for any sort of young engineer early in
his or her career listening to this
podcast whoa what advice would you give
today for someone who's looking to enter
the field and make a big impact
yeah that's a great question so the
thing that comes to mind here is you
know when I was early in my career as I
mentioned a little bit earlier I was
really focused on honing my technical
craft and really wanted to be the best
possible engineer I could be on a
technical level wanted to learn all
kinds of patterns and operations and
various other pieces of what it meant to
be a well-rounded software engineer and
I think I really neglected to look at
the context of what the work I was doing
how it fit into the businesses that I
was working in until much later in my
career so it really wasn't until late in
my career at Yahoo some some of it at
Zynga and really what really pushed me
was starting my own company and knowing
that everything I worked on had a direct
connection right to what the company was
trying to do where I really understood
what it meant to fully understand how
your work fits into the context of the
business so what I often tell younger
engineers now some of them naturally at
age 19 just have a business sense and
that you know is is amazing to see and
when that happens great but a lot of
Engineers I see early on in their career
are really focused on their technical
skills and don't look at the how what
their
moves the bottom line for their business
or the top line for their business or
the mission of their business all of
which are critically important if you're
actually going to be really successful
as an engineer if you want all those
things that you're working towards in
your career like mastery and autonomy
and purpose and all the ability to
create and innovate the way that you're
gonna get those things is by making a
big you are you know if you're working
at a company the company has a mission
it has a bottom line it has a focus
think about how your technology moves
that forward and then start looking for
the leverage points about where your
technology can I advanced that right and
the earlier you start thinking in that
context that sort of that pragmatism
that I mentioned before in the context
of the business that you're working in
the better engineer you're going to be
because building a really beautiful tech
that doesn't advance anybody's goals is
really fun
you know I like messing around with home
automation stuff all the time
but at the end of the day what creates
value in the long run is trying to
advance the mission or enterprise that
you're involved with and so that's the
biggest mistake I see young engineers
make is just focusing too much on am I
good software engineer can i code and
not enough on what is my code doing in
the world or whether it be the impact
that it's making for people or the
impact on the bottom line of the
business that I'm that I'm in right
great
what about mentorship like well that's
one thing I haven't asked you about were
there I'm sure your mentor now to people
we earlier in your career with their
important mentors for you and would you
advise young people to look for that as
they get started yeah absolutely
the the story about mentorship that I
always tell people is that when I did
graduate school it was 2001 and it was a
very very bad time in in tech it was you
know post first dot-com crash and I had
an offer from Yahoo to go work there
full-time and I was graduating it was
May of 2001 I was graduating with a
degree in computer science and I got a
call from my then manager at the time
who said hey I'm gonna FedEx you your
offer letter
I want it was like it was like Monday
he's like I want it bye you're gonna
sign it you're gonna FedEx it back it's
gonna be on my desk by Wednesday mm-hmm
and I was like what's the big deal like
what's going on he's like just do it and
I was like okay so I got the thing I
signed it I FedExed it back and then the
day after he got it and my offer was
confirmed Yahoo announced like layoffs
hiring freeze the whole deal so I was
this close and I because I was so
focused on on Yahoo and had been a part
of it from early on I wasn't like
looking other places or like
interviewing or getting my resume
together and I was always a little bit
of a tinkerer or builder not an academic
so my academic performance was shall we
say spotty and so I would have been in
real real trouble and that moment from
for me was just a master class in in
mentorship and in management and that he
knew what was going on with every one of
his people at any given time and he made
sure to think about them to protect them
to make sure that they had what they
needed to be successful and as I
continue to work for him
I saw him demonstrate that in so many
different ways and I ran into someone
after years of not working with with
that mentor I ran into someone who knew
him and they mentioned that he had been
following everything that I'd been doing
that he had been talking proudly about
lend up and all this other stuff and I
hadn't talked to him in a really long
time and it's just you know it further
cemented that he was just the kind of
person who just genuinely cared about
the people that he worked with and the
purple people who worked for him yeah so
I always try to model my mentorship and
management on that is really learning
about the people that I'm working with
and investing in them and knowing I'm
not naturally like a networker
and someone who keeps in touch with
people on a regular basis and so it
doesn't come naturally to me but if it
matters so much in the connections that
you make in the long term so it's
something I've had to train and sort of
grow and myself right that's that's a
great story
yeah okay last question yep if we
imagine the world five years from now
yeah and think about all of the
potential and possibilities for lend up
yeah like what does lendable look like
verse from now on your in your vision in
your dreams absolutely so my dream for
lend up has always been that we create
an entire ecosystem of products that are
all constructive for consumers but are
all designed for different use at use
cases and different types of consumers
in that realm of people who don't have a
lot of options and we connect those all
together with technology that can
essentially look at an individual
customer and figure out what they need
to get to the next level so when they
come and they apply there's a product
for them there's something that they can
start with that help solve their
immediate need and then we customize a
path for that person through a series of
our products to help them improve their
financial lives over time and that may
be credit or maybe other things you know
budgeting and financial management you
know there's so many opportunities to
help people manage their financial lives
more effectively bill pay you know I
mean you name it right there's so many
things we can do and so I want to build
a whole suite of financial services sort
of what what Amex is to the wealthy
business traveler in terms this whole
suite of services that they provide that
are all cohesive and work together I
want to provide that to the half of the
country that doesn't have access to
banks in a constructive way and I want
to tie it all together with machine
learning that customizes a path for
every single person so every single
person comes gets a customized product
and then has a very customized path for
them this is what you do next to grow
your financial well-being and then that
adapts as they behave right if they if
they're succeeding it's you know it
continues if they are struggling then we
we change the way it works for them as
we learn more about them and how they
operate right and so that's the dream so
there's a bunch of products that we have
that we're thinking about next in terms
of continuing to build out that
ecosystem but it's a huge huge market
you know credit cards in the u.s. is 350
billion depends on who you ask but
somewhere between 350 billion to 450
billion in revenues since it's not a
small market and that's just in the
United States and so we have plenty to
grow in where we're at right now but we
want to continue to innovate and
new products to the ecosystem as well
terrific well that's an amazing amazing
vision you guys have made a huge amount
of progress and I was looking forward to
seeing kind of what comes next you too
yeah great to see you thanks for the
time
thanks thanks for having me awesome
thank you
you